all right these next two stories are
going to contain video clips uh really
not suitable for children there's no
gore or anything like that but you'll
understand i think as we go
uh so donald trump held a rally over the
weekend just another rally right who
cares well this one was actually one of
the most disturbing and alarming rallies
i can remember maybe the most alarming
i've seen from trump because it had all
the normal things it had the lies and
we'll look at some of the lies it had
the delusional crowds whose ignorance
has been completely weaponized which we
will look at the cheering at horrible
things all of that
but this rally in the important election
state of iowa had some notable and key
differences first as dino bedalla wrote
for cnn
key iowa republican elected officials
were there
at the georgia rally a couple weeks ago
trump attacked that state's republican
leaders this time this weekend in iowa
despite the insanity of trump for the
last six years trump losing the white
house for republicans in 2018 losing the
senate and the white house in 2020 uh
inciting a riot on january 6th iowa's
republican leaders were all there and
they are still supporting him which is a
very dark signal for democracy chuck
grassley as dean obadala wrote after
criticizing trump's incitement of the
january six riots was right there in
iowa this weekend praising donald trump
so after all of it
in now october of 2021 trump is still in
control of the party the blind loyalty
is still there and trump spent the rally
telling horrible corrosive demonstrable
lies about the election of 2020 so let's
jump right in trump heavily into the
xenophobia here he is saying the afghan
refugees or people we'll quote soon be
hearing about he seems to be alluding to
soon they're going to carry out attacks
against the u.s and you'll be hearing
about it it was oh it was great they had
no idea who was getting on those planes
we still don't have any idea only three
percent were qualified to be taken
to a place called the united states of
america isn't that something three
percent you're going to be hearing from
those people over the coming years in a
very bad way right trump then talking
about his travel ban as something to
prevent people from coming here who want
to blow up our cities
the democrat bill will also
admit every foreign national
previously denied
under my national security travel ban
remember i had the travel ban everyone
said oh what a horrible thing i said no
we really don't want people in our
country who are going to blow up our
cities if you don't mind
we don't want
we don't want fifth avenue blown up now
remember that the travel ban was
actually targeted at countries that were
not source countries for people who came
here and attacked the united states
trump then moving on to the topic of
abortion saying a democrats support
killing babies even after birth now
that's murder no one supports that it's
also not legal but take a listen to
trump quickly
the bill abolishes the hyde amendment
forcing taxpayers to fund the far left's
extreme abortion agenda ripping babies
from their mother's womb right up until
the moment of birth
and in fact killing babies even after
birth you saw that
in virginia with the governor of
virginia
after birth so that was a widely
debunked fake news story from the right
um a couple years ago actually it's not
true
the crowd maybe doesn't know maybe
doesn't care who knows but they cheer
uh so then we get into the 2020 lies
here's donald trump teasing the idea
that he could he might come back because
remember he didn't concede hillary
conceded he didn't legitimate they
called it everything in the book it was
fine
when i say it now here's the difference
hillary conceded
i never conceded
that's how you fire up
a low information crowd
then trump saying the corrupt media
and democrats used covid to put in place
mail-in voting
it's hard to even exactly follow what
he's saying but it's part of the 2020
big lie that he continues
these people are so corrupt the media
look i don't need to do this but the
media is corrupt and you know what when
i started i'm so proud of this
two things i proved number one the
elections are totally corrupt in our
country they have been for a long time
but never like they were this last time
they used covid
in order to cheat and rig
and the other thing is how dishonest the
media was because they were at 96
approval rating before i came along and
now they're like in what the 20s
and then just yeah just to show you how
much he's in control of this crowd the
crowd actually starts chanting trump one
as trump just tells lies about the 2020
election
but let's hope he does our country needs
it arizona needs it and with all of
those numbers being so horrible
we did
as i've said before trump without his
followers is really not much
but with the followers it is something
very serious and scary trump then
continuing to struggle with certain
words minneapolis of course minneapolis
that's just par for the course now
that's not working out too well you see
in minnesota minneapolis there i went to
a conference in minneapolis once it was
weird really really weird trump then
referring to someone as uh personippity
instead of persnickety
he was
with us all the way every time i needed
something you know he's very persnippity
sometimes right he's tough persnickety
of course means fussy persnippity me i
don't know what that one means your
guess is as good as mine trump then
hilariously mentions
i mean apparently he's serious he'll
quickly finish building the border wall
when what are you talking about we will
quickly complete the border wall and we
will end illegal immigration
once and for all we will have to start
it all over again remember he was going
to do the border wall in one term we all
knew he wasn't and he didn't didn't
happen
does the crowd crowd know that do they
care i have no idea
uh maybe this is that same kind of
magical thinking we talked about where
they see themselves as being in like a
war where individual facts don't matter
just if trump says it you've got to
cheer for it because you're part of the
crowd is that what's going on here
and then ultimately trump
wound down the rally with a completely
unintelligible rant about critical race
theory including in the military we will
ban critical race theory in our
classrooms we will ban
that horrible crazy critical race theory
in our military we will ban it from our
workplaces we will better from our
federal state and local governments it
will be banned permanently banned and
will never be allowed to come back again
i don't even know what i can really say
about this other than as i've said
before
i find it sort of quaint when they talk
about banning a theory
what they mean is banning the teaching
of it right like how how do you ban a
theory
but it seems what they mean is they want
a gag order which is of course very
authoritarian and very much a
restriction on what people can talk
about quite frankly so absolutely
delusional event the crowd goers as much
as trump we're gonna listen to the crowd
goers in this next segment but the
really dangerous cherry on top is that
at this stage of the game this late in
the game prominent iowa republicans
chuck grassley
still openly supportive of donald trump
after everything he did
2024 is really looking as rough as you
can imagine
and we'll have time to talk about it
once we get beyond the midterms next
let's talk about the rally attendees
one of our sponsors is atlas vpn in the
year 2021 many computer security experts
say everybody everybody should be using
a vpn whenever you connect to the
internet atlas vpn keeps your
information private from big tech
companies from your internet service
provider even from governments atlas vpn
helps you stay protected from hackers
trying to steal your data an atlas vpn
even lets you watch shows and movies on
netflix and other streaming services you
would otherwise only be able to access
from other countries i use atlas vpn on
all of my devices phone computer tablet
whenever i'm connected to the internet
it's so easy to use you sign up install
it turn it on and you're done out of
sight out of mind you stay protected and
right now my audience can get atlas vpn
for a dollar 39 a month
with a 30 day money back guarantee you
just have to go to atlas v
dot pn slash pacman the link is right
underneath this video